welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down Aquaman in the lost
[Music]
kingdom the DCU is now at an end and we
have a lot to talk about throughout this
video we're going to be going over what
happens in the movie The Drama behind
the scenes the future of the DC you and
a lot more though this movie is
predicted to sink at the box office I
think some things can be salvaged and
perhaps this isn't Jason M's final
voyage at DC so come with us as we
plunder the plot but be warned me
hearties there are spoilers ahead he not
even a pirate but please hit the thumbs
up if you enjoy and make sure you
subscribe for videos like this every day
the way huge thank you for clicking this
now let's get into Aquaman
2 4 years ago I was basically
unemployed a Wanderer with no
home but now I'm a husband and a
father and I wouldn't have it any other
way I'm know how you do pops my job was
a little less stressful than yours okay
so I'll be talking about what happened
behind the scenes as we go through the
movie but I mainly want to focus on the
plot first however some of the stuff's
difficult to avoid and it's kind of
crazy what's been going on Aquaman 2
picks up in the aftermath of the first
film with Arthur Curry ruling over
Atlantis however he walks Between Two
Worlds and on the surface is raising a
family this is along with his wife
redacted who you can tell they cut out
as much as possible now I did have a
part of my video discussing things going
on but unfortunately it got hit with
limited ads don't know if that was
because it got Mass flagged or whether
it's a touchy topic but I'm just going
to steer clear of it and dive straight
into the next part it is weird when
stuff like that happens I didn't
actually say anything bad to talk about
the controversial elements just skied
around the edge and said why the Press
said the role was reduced either way
what you need to know is that they've
now move the focus over to Arthur and or
whether that was always the direction
they'd go we we don't know but it leads
into what's an adventure that's all
about family their mother Arthur's son
and father they all play a big role with
black mantis still wanting to avenge his
father too now earlier in the air James
ju told Empire he was pulling from some
retro horror to inspire the film's look
this was mainly the 60s movie Planet of
the vampire which visually this film
borrows a lot from there's green and
black a wild vibrancy of colors and lots
of things going on visually that make
the movie pop as I mentioned it picks up
in the aftermath of the first film in
which we saw Black Manta air drift in
the sea picked up by sailor as he was
nurse back by Dr Steven Shin an Atlantis
obsessive played by Jim from the office
the movie sees Manta wanting to Avengers
father and we see a shin in his
expedition unearth an ancient evil the
film opens up with basically the Montage
from Thor of and Thunder with Aquaman
going through what his life's been like
you get lots of flashes to the first
movie and see him at home being a parent
that swix Guinness with his dad and also
has to deal with the alantis council it
continues the family Motif though with
that even being brought across to the
villain shin and covers the lost kingdom
which is known as necris which was led
by an ancient evil that was named cordax
cordax was alin's brother and he used a
mineral called oracol kulum to further
his Industries and build up his kingdom
however this was extremely toxic and it
poisoned the oceans along with the
surface atlan went to him and was like
just stop F I get probably get in
trouble for that H but after a big fight
they put a curse on the kingdom which
was then sealed in his blood now that
kind of shows a disagreement between
Brothers is of course carried across to
or and Arthur who are going to have to
write the wrongs of the past now though
Manta discovers a big monster cave man
still decides to go in it like yeah
we're just going to go in and it's here
he comes across the black Trident
grabbing it he's somewhat possessed by
cordax and he leads him to the location
of the mcau culin now 5 months pass and
we learn that temperatures on the Earth
are heating up and that there's been a
plague which has swept through Atlantis
we learn the Oracle culum emits
greenhouse gases and there is lot of
talk about global warming in the movie
the planet's heating up authors rules
Rocky and even William defo volco gets
pooi off screen when one of manta's
culen raids leads into him attacking
Atlantis we then start to see how
powerful he's become Mira gets injured
and it becomes Amber her in the Lost
character and there along with his
friendly octopus tofo arth the heads to
rescue his brother now script wise the
whole thing is a bit cliche and it's I
don't think it's going to win any awards
for writing however where I think the
film really excels is in all its
locations and unique characters as
Arthur tries to track down man we go to
some brilliant places and meet lots of
unique and interesting creatures the
kingfish he like a Jabba the Hut style
gangster that leads Orman Arthur to a
place known as Devil's steep this is a
vast jungle filled with giant
grasshoppers and a mechanical almost
resident evil for style Island at the
heart of it all this keeps the movie
interesting and engaging with one really
getting to flex his horror muscles as
well now I do think recently the DC went
a bit too much on the demon behind the
scenes thing controlling it all and this
has been seen in a number of different
films the first Shazam did it Black Adam
did it too and these are used as a way
to empower the villains still though
Sauron sorry cordax is easily the best
one and I think that's down to how good
one is with horror to be fair sandig is
to and yet it's nice to see elements
like this in the film who really steals
the show though is Patrick Wilson with
him becoming the MVP of the entire movie
for me mang goes on a great Arc will get
into in just a bit and his back and
forth with Arthur really makes the movie
sore now after things go hay are a
devil's breath we learn a bit more about
the curse on cordax this was something
that was sealed with blood and thus only
the descendants of atlan are able to
lift it this puts Arthur's new son in
the crosshairs and Arthur rushes home to
find it destroyed although the trailers
made it look like man to kill Tommy they
managed to save him by putting him on
life support I was kind of thinking it
might be a dad for a dad but in the end
they don't go that route however what
they do is Storm necris where Manta is
about to sacrifice Junior Shin ends up
saving him and me is able to grab the
kid but at this point Manta throws the
Trident caught by m he then becomes
possessed with the Allure of the throne
becoming too much you have to remember
he's pretty much like cordax was and
that he should have been the ruler but
was cast out by his brother thus him and
Arthur end up having a fight but
Arthur's managed to do the old the old
you know the one look inside you dig
deep that sort of thing now all that
kind of stuff it can be really cliche
they actually do something great and
build off the first film that's so
Arthur below the arena saying how he
would have liked to have been a brother
to him too that line gets played up here
again and I thought it was a really good
way to play off that first meeting
unfortunately though Arthur smacked off
the Altar and his blood spills which
unleashes cordex still though he manages
to destroy him and the tried in one Blow
by throwing his through the center of
cxes it's a cordax moment and in the end
the planet is saved with Atlanta
deciding to reveal itself to the world
I'm sorry guys now it's kind of like
when wakanda did it and Aquaman even
Ends by saying I am Aquaman still a bit
like Marvel app but still it brings the
message that we should all work together
which is very much what the movie is
about or is given another chance and
they go with a story he died in the
Battle and man gets to go out and just
experience the world guy was pretty much
he was a bit of a racist to be fair in
that first movie he hated everyone in
the surface world I know that word's a
bit strong but he just didn't like us
and even earlier in the movie author was
saying look mate you your Prejudice it's
holding you back so this chance he gets
to go out and see the world and finally
embrace all the different cultures and
that kind of takes us into the post
credit scene which builds off the back
of a J from earlier in the movie in it
we see or eating a delicious delicious
burger that ties back to the line from
the movie in which M said he never tried
one this is because there's no burgers
in Atlantis and he also stuffs a little
cockroach in because that was set up
earlier too and yeah that's it so the
final final scene of the DC EU of all
time is or eating a burger now the
people who' have seen this as you can
guess it's DC the DC fans no one hates
DC more than DC fans they're in a bloody
uproar and I think as well it's kind of
disappointing the DC EU goes out on a
lane joke kind of sums up how it was run
though but I was kind of surprised at
how they decided to go with it I
actually thought they might close out
with something thanking the fans for the
past 10 years you know cuz Man of Steel
was released in 2013 and for everyone
who stuck with the universe for the last
decade I thought that we might get
something a bit more endgame closes out
with a cast names all on a big thing
with all the actor signatures a
silhouette and clips from their
appearances for this it's kind of weird
and at the very least I was expecting
some kind of acknowledgement The Flash
was originally supposed to be the final
film in the DCU but release dat got
moved about so maybe that should be seen
more as a celebration whereas this one's
kind of just a sort of Standalone film
now in the end though this is how we've
got it and it kind of reminds me a bit
of the poem The Hollow Men by TS Elliott
in case you don't know what that is yet
just just as a reference it closes out
with the following lines this is the way
the world ends this is the way the world
ends this is the way the world ends not
with a bang but a wimper and that's kind
of what I feel about the way the DC EU
is ending as it closes out with a
whimper instead of a big bang it's sad
now there were also other scenes that
were supposed to appear in the movie
involving two different versions of
Batman that were basically shrouding as
bat that's because the release date of
this changed which also meant the Batman
in the movie was a different actor now
in one version of the movie we had Ben
afflac returning which was leaked due to
his name being spotted on a Warner
Brothers tour once a new got out Jason
Mamo embraced the publicity and posted
an image of him and Ben together this
was going to tease Return of the actor
and he was going to come back as Batman
in some form or another sort of like the
way they ended Black Adam by teasing
Henry caval and it was clear there were
plans to bring the SN verse back however
they also shot one involving Michael
Keaton which was going to tie to the
Flash's original ending in case you
don't know that movie was supposed to
culminate with keep balls stepping out
the limo and then Supergirl arriving on
the scene in the end they changed this
to Clooney so once again they could end
it on a joke the Aquaman teas was then
shot to explain why this film was still
connected to it so we're not wondering
why he wasn't wiped out during the flash
if anyone cares it's it's lots of timey
why me wibbly wobbly stuff however the
exx said they didn't want to tease the
universe that might not be coming and
thus both versions of the film had their
Batman scenes removed when I say both
versions yeah just to clarify I mean one
had Affleck in it and the other version
had Katon either way we know that people
like Blue Beetle are said to be the
first hero in the DCU but Superman's the
first movie in the DCU yeah it's a bit
weird but either way that's how they've
kept things like the post credit scenes
still in that movie in all honesty I
feel like they know they messed up by
announcing that none of these films
really matter and I don't know why they
didn't hold off until 2024 there was no
need to shout out these were all getting
scrapped before the films released and
with Superman dropping in 2025 at the
earliest I feel they could have held off
until then it's clear though they've
lost all their faith in this stuff and
the studio didn't even have a red carpet
Premiere a sequel to a billion dollar
superhero movie not getting that that is
kind of wild to me and it's crazy how
much the landscape's changed in the last
year personally I think it's just a case
of oversaturation as we've had so many
middling superhero movies at this point
that more often than not you're going to
be disappointed so in some ways people
just seem to be switched off and that's
abundant in the DC eu2 which sucks cuz I
do genuinely wish this film the best I
kind of feel in general like comic book
movies have become like comic books
themselves in which even the aid readers
aren't that interested in picking up all
the SP enough stuff now what I mean by
that is like look I'm a massive reader
got loads of graphic novels but when I
go to the comic shop I don't pick up
every single issue out there what I tend
to pick up is the stuff I'm interested
in and that's also what I tend to read
and just keep picking up now when
there's a massive crossover event
involving a lot of characters I'll pick
up every book from that for example I've
got all this stuff from Civil War but I
don't necessarily think I'd pick up all
those characters if they weren't
connected to that story that's kind of
what I feel like with the shed universes
2o and stuff you wouldn't normally check
out you ended up doing it because it was
all connected to that story now though
these universes that story pulling them
together it just isn't there and though
people go see the big stuff they're not
there for every single film and TV show
so yeah that's kind of how I view the
market I know there's hundreds of
factors involved in why these movies
aren't performing well um and I am
crying that you know that that first
movie for example that didn't have a
great opening weekend but over time it
built an audience and yeah go see it if
you're interested in superhero films
either way that's how he clouds out the
DC euu with it not teasing anything at
all and just being a full stop now as
for my thoughts on the movie it's kind
of a weird one as I realized when I was
in the cinema that this was going to be
the last time that I watched the DCU
film in the theaters it's been 10 been
10 years since it Kickstart with Man of
Steel and I've spent a third of my life
following this franchise it's kind of
sad that it's gone out like this as I
think had this been released before
Black Adam Shazam and the Flash the
conversation around it would be a bit
different the script is a bit all over
the place and you can spot the re-shoot
a mile away but at its core I think it's
an enjoyable film I think the horror
elements work really well and there's a
real sense of wonder to what happens
throughout I know the CGI is getting
criticized as being a bit flat but
compared to the green screening in quto
Mania it it slaps am modok's cheeks
completely with both hands MO is just
having a blast and when he's going back
and forth with or it really works to the
point I would have loved to have seen
something with them later down the line
at this point though the writing it is
on the wall all of the main three though
feel like they really evolved past the
first film and Manta even builds off
that too loved seeing him at the end
refuse to take Arthur's hand and it
brings things full circle from when he
let his dad die in the first movie still
though I don't think this would have
been enough to save the dce euu and like
all movies you know it isn't perfect you
kind of don't know where things are
going at points and characters do make
very strange logic choices also that in
ible costume that he doesn't wear over
his head still turns invisible just
stuff like that it's a nitpicky but yeah
it just kind of dings the movie a bit
there's also some plots that have
clearly been cut down with stuff like
the council that gets brushed to the
side the global warming thing keeps
popping up but it's never really a main
thing and sort of feels like an
afterthought also they did my man
William defo dirty and I doubt he's
going to be William the friend to the
Warner Brothers in the future cuz worst
thing is they killed a guy and didn't
even Warner Brother still I enjoyed this
way more than I thought I would and I
think that it's better than the first
film that had that Pitbull song which
killed it for me but now I like that and
this was a nice Step Beyond it obviously
the social media andgo lifting the day
the movie releases as well that's a bit
weird and I know lots of people had saw
it and then were asked to not talk about
it online there were rumors that this
test did lower than back as well and we
all know what happened with that too so
there was this weird embargo that made
people think it was absolutely terrible
but in all honesty see it's better the
most superhero movies that we've had
recently sure not all the jokes land but
Arthur and M get a great Arc and
Visually it's harded than I it's
striking so in the end the said the
whole thing's over I'm ready to let go
and see where we go next unfortunately
the dceu will always feel like wasted
potential to me but I can take solace in
the fact we got Snider's Trilogy at
least and some solid movies along the
way I we'll talk about where things are
going to go in just a bit but as for now
this gets a seven out out of 10 I'm nice
like that now if you enjoy the content
and want to help support us we're
currently selling some all connected
shirts these massively help to pay the
bills and it also means you get some
cool merch to rock we also have a
membership program that you can sign up
to by clicking the join button and as a
thank you you'll get early access to
videos now as for the future of DC we
know James gun's currently working on
his upcoming film title Superman Legacy
the cast is stacked and things are
really ramping up with a kickstarting
his first phase title Gods and Monsters
you may have also seen reports that
Warner Brothers are in trouble
financially and thus it seems like the
focus is solely on that though they have
other films announced I don't actually
think Productions on them started yet
and thus I think they're going to see if
Superman's a success first and then roll
into the others shortly after that
perhaps they'll get the dailies back and
go from there but I think they're
probably holding off for a while to see
how things go all the DC films this year
have underperformed and from a business
point of view that makes the most sense
normally when you get these universes
they put the car before the horse and
start making films before they even know
if that first one's a hit so I think
being patient is a smart thing to do
especially with all the financial
pressure resting on gun's shoulders in
the meantime we have sequels to the
Batman and Joker so it's not like we're
going to be starved for DC content
there's also the penguin show and Matt
re Zen one which has said to be part of
the DCU Creature Commandos is coming as
well with Superman Legacy being a big
kickoff point so they can really wait to
see how that performs and then decide if
they want to bet the House on Gun
there's also rumors that they could be
merging with Paramount and who knows how
the landscape of the studio is going to
look in 5 years either way though it
seems fine on the surface it's clear
behind the scenes that there's been a
lot of pressure I think G could
definitely pull it off though and so far
he's made a great DC movie a great DC
series and obviously a great Trilogy at
Marvel Studios now in the run up to this
Jason Mamo also said when it comes to
Aquaman it's not looking good in an
interview with ET he said sorry
Entertainment Tonight when I say he's
interviewing ET not him this
is likely I think your last time playing
Aquaman you know I don't necessarily
want it to be the end right yeah so I
don't think it's really like a it was a
choice I think obviously the whole you
know James and Peter and DC wanting to
start the new thing up so I I don't know
if it will be because the truth of it is
I mean I guess if the audience loves it
but right now I'm
like it's not not looking too good now
earlier in the a when actors were making
public statements about their DC future
you might remember Mamoa did one too he
said that he'd spoken to gun about
making his dream project and seemed to
be ecstatic that that was going down now
because of this many have suspected
he'll return for the DCU but he'll be
playing someone DC
new that is lobo and in the same
interview with ET they went into it and
teased it the
DCU is effectively and in what
conversations have there's rumors
there's things going around have you and
James had the discussion
about what happens you being a part of
the DC Universe again in the future I
know James Gunn is definitely a fan
Peter saffron's obviously very close to
if there's a place in their world for me
I would love to be a part of it having
said that you know i' like this
character me for 12 years so it really
comes down to I think they're really
amazing men and if if there's something
that uh the fans love I'm sure they
would honor honor that but I definitely
think there's I'll be this is my home
Warner is a DC is definitely my home so
that's all I'll say yeah
there's I read I
read and I saw that Lobo cover and I was
like
well look at the guy look at the guy I
was a big Lobo fan growing up so I've
have every comic so that would be really
cool that would be cool so you're
telling me right this guy isn't love
Lobo after those comments and the dream
project one it's OB it's obvious mate
it's bloody obvious and yeah I'd love to
see him in that role too in case you
don't know Lobo is a bounty and air and
he travels to Stars cracking up Bas
dishes guy's got a cool bike is super
strong and powerful and would be the
kind of character guns already adapt out
writing lowo has already had a really
interesting Arc and when he first came
out he was seen as a villain man was
arrogant and self-centered and the last
of his kind after wiping them out for
fun still though we watched him develop
as a character and change his ways which
would be something cool that they could
do in the films there's lots of ways I
think they could take him and once the
fan art starts you know that's it I
think if this film flops it won't be
down to him either and with him saying
DC's his home I'd love to see him back
again I don't think he can be blamed if
this flops and I think at the moment
there's just a lack of interest in
movies in general everything's kind of
been done and we've seen lots of Bombs
over the last year you kind of hit a
point where almost every comic book
movie's been done and we've got way more
content than what we've ever had before
so people are more selective over what
they watch with comic book movies not
being the guaranteed success that they
once were still though I wish M all the
best and he genuinely seems like a
really cool dude guys's been going
around doing the press and giving back
to fans so I hope we see him return in
some form or
another I think I know someone might go
to help
us you look rough
good job little brother High fire do not
call me
brother I cannot believe you let this
happen yeah well I hate this job true
king built Bridges
right true king builds
Bridges anyway that wraps up the video
and huge thank you for checking it out
please drop a like and leave your
comments below as there's more here to
talk about than just the movie story
lots of things going on lots of things
in the future and yeah I'd love to hear
you guys thoughts so make sure you drop
them below now if you want some else to
watch we've got a video on screen right
now where we talk about all the stuff
going on with Jonathan Mages did that
with mt it was a great little
conversation and yeah definitely head
over there right after this by the way
huge thank you for sing through the
video I've been your host Paul you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace